good evening we have had record-breaking
heat today and ted will have more
details about that in a moment but if
you're worried about your car
in this heat you're not alone the
extreme temperatures can really take a
toll on our cars
and the freeway service patrol is
noticing that more people are having
problems joe moeller went along
with the patrol to see how the heat
changes their daily routine
we all see the freeway service patrol
vehicles out on our local freeways
helping stranded drivers
well when the heat turns up that means
these guys are working extra hard
on hot days like we are experiencing the
freeway service patrol says calls for
service roughly double
do you guys top out with a gold van
right there at spring mountain north
one driver can respond to up to 15 calls
a shift
there are nine drivers each shift from
blown out tires to overheating engines
driver james cooper says the extreme
heat takes a toll on our cars
he says there are some things people
should be considering when driving
around in these temperatures
make sure you have a full tank of gas
and keep your uh
double check your coolant and your air
and your tires
you guys need any water we got some of
the truck bro okay looking now i
appreciate y'all
no problem dispatch monitors freeway
cameras for stranded cars and receive
calls for service from nhp
if you run into car trouble pull to the
shoulder and in shade if possible during
the extreme heat to avoid overheating
if you find yourself on the side of the
road in need of help from the freeway
service patrol
you can dial star and hp reporting in
north las vegas joe mohler 8 news now
the freeway service patrol says it's
also extremely important to carry water
with you because if you are broken down
it could take some time before someone
can get to you